all right Doctor Who time again and I'm
picking up from where I left off talking
about villains last time I did one time
appearances this time I'm gonna tackle
recurring villains again restricting
myself to the current version of the
show I'm not dealing with classic Doctor
Who right now and to be clear in terms
of definitions a recurring villain has
to have appeared in more than one story
two partners only count as one story and
they have to have been the villain
clearly in at least two of those
appearances they do not have to have
been the central villain for both
appearances but they have to have been
very clearly intended as villains in two
appearances at least so using those as
the ground rules that gives us 11
recurring villains and the Doctor Who
current era let's get going
number 11 the Slitheen I make no bones
about the fact that I have a lot of
problems with the Slitheen they're
juvenile I don't particularly care for
that weird baby face design but there
are some ways in which they're really
used effectively when they're being
played by the humans as opposed to the
big CGI or puppeted things they work
quite well in their intimidating and
they have a sense of menace to them and
it works especially well when we get the
second appearance with boomtown and just
dealing with only one of them who's now
the last of her family and you get it's
almost a little bit of a head of a
lector clarice starling vibe when it's
her talking with the doctor now which
one you want to consider to be Hannibal
which one Clarice I'll leave that up to
you but it's that kind of back and forth
play and that second one did make up
some ground number 10 Cassandra there's
some really cool things about Cassandra
as a villain just the kind of the play
on Plastic Surgery and how far she is
from being anything even vaguely
resembling human anymore yet still
considers herself to be the last pure
human alive just the irony of that alone
is wonderful and then her arrogance
around that label that she's given
herself last human alive and she's just
so high on herself it's a great send up
of just that sort of high society it's
it's a very British kind of send up in
that way but you know Doctor Who is
inherently British at many times so
works wonderfully she doesn't rank
hiring those because for me she is a
little
one note and also her I felt her second
appearance was a rather forced all
things considered although that said I
think the little coated that they had
for her kind of giving her a moment and
of humanity was was a nice way to wrap
up her story number nine the Nestene the
Nestea I really feel like we're still
waiting for a really great story to
really focus on these guys that said
when they get used they get used pretty
well they served their function for a
sort of that initial intro to the doctor
for the new times and when they popped
up again as part of the Pandorica that
was a really clever use of the
duplicates and that sort of payoff with
Rory ending up being one of them and the
eventual redemption for him was also
really nicely played so there's nothing
inherently wrong with the way the
Nestene have been done so far I do feel
like there's a lot of untapped potential
in what could be done with them and they
just need the right story in the right
writer to really tap that potential
number eight Madame Kovarian in some
ways she's a little bit cartoonish
between the eye patch and just how sort
of art she is it's it's a little bit of
a caricature but it's effective
nonetheless because she starts out with
that mysteriously she's just showing up
oh but don't know what's going on in
just the vitriol we get out of her when
she's confronting the doctor head-on and
just this this hatred that we don't even
know where it's really coming from but
there's no question that it's there she
sells that really well despite being a
little bit OneNote at times she's just
used really effectively in the way that
she gets closed down courtesy of Amy
Pond that was really satisfying and
you've got to give credit for that
because the elimination of a villain
isn't satisfying if the villain didn't
work on some level so I gotta give her
that number seven the Sontarans now
we're starting to get into some really
good stuff and their two-parter was a
really good return for them and it
really sold what sort of makes them
menacing this war mentality and the fact
that they really crave battle and that
militaristic mind it all just fits
together plus a really good redesign
that kept the heart of that original
design from the classic era but updated
it just enough the sometimes probably
would have ranked higher
they have been played for jokes more
recently I think we can blame Strax for
that now I love Strax as a character but
because he's become so comical a lot of
the late appearances of Sontarans have
also been played for comedy and I think
they kind of need to another episode
where they are the full-on antagonists
and so we can bump them up to where they
really should be in the first place
number six the Cybermen now when the
Cybermen are used well they're used
extremely well however they're not
always used well in the new series well
on balance I have mixed feelings about
sort of the alternate world cybus men
that we have gotten for pretty much all
of the new series I can't deny that they
are effective and things like the sounds
of those boots tromping the tone of
their voice and just the overall design
again it's just enough of that classic
design but it's been updated I like them
when they're used in smaller pieces
I love the appearance of the partial
Cyberman in the Pandorica story
I loved closing time and I think there's
sort of smaller quieter uses of the
Cybermen as this sort of insidious thing
that only takes one and they get at you
you're in a whole lot of trouble when
they make them bigger like nightmare and
silver just things didn't work for me so
that when they go large-scale I feel
they don't hold up as well you you keep
the story smaller with them and they can
be really scary number 5 the master now
in all honesty I'm not a huge fan of
John Sims first appearance as the master
I think he went a little ittle to almost
kind of wacky with it I'm not a huge fan
of that portrayal the characters still
used very well especially in terms of
his impact on the doctor that's all
played very well the character himself
wasn't bad but I didn't really sell it
for me however when he returned for
David Tennant's last story I thought he
was fantastic that version of the master
who was just completely gone any
pretense of sanity is gone and not only
is he the same homicidal maniac he's
always been he's now just completely
unhinged she's barely got a grasp on
reality and that time with his
performance John seems really sold that
because he'd had these little moments of
clarity and but then he'd just start to
lose it again and that balance was
really
effective and also really scary there's
something really frightening about
somebody who when he's collected would
have no problem obliterating you but
then they're even more dangerous when
they're unhinged and seeing both sides
of that and that he's not really in
control of himself anymore number four
the great intelligence now this is one
that I'm actually liked in every
appearance but I really started to
appreciate it when I started putting
this list together just how well this
character was used initial appearance
was a little bit off-putting the whole
episode of the snowmen was a little bit
up and down in a lot of ways but for
having it voiced by Ian McKellen first
of all it was a really master stroke and
then having him come back using the face
of dr. Simeon which gave Richard he
grant much more to do than he did when
he appeared in the snowman and really to
Bank on his inherent gravitas that he
has as an actor works wonderfully even
if it was just that little appearance at
the end of the bells of st. John that
just immediately hooked me into him as a
character again and then seeing what he
went through just to torture the doctor
because usually these villains have much
bigger plans revenge is actually very
rarely a motivation for a villain in
Doctor Who so to have somebody this bent
on just taking out the doctor and
destroying him as completely as is
possible even at the expense of his own
life that's something we don't really
see for the most part there's plenty of
characters with grudges against the
doctor but if they get to take out a
Grunch on him that's a side thing to
some other world dominating scheme
they've got not the case with this guy
not in his last appearance anyways he's
after the doctor he's going for the
doctor and he takes him out he wins
really it gets undone by Clara but
that's some pretty frightening stuff
when he puts the doctor through number
three the weeping angels now I will be
completely honest I was really skeptical
the first time we found out that the
weeping angels were going to come back
for another story they were so effective
in blink I thought there's no way this
is gonna work a second time around well
I was proved wrong and they worked
pretty much every time they've come back
at least where they've been the central
part of the story blink is pretty much
flawless time of the Angels stone and
flesh that is a great two-parter and it
really builds up that you know a couple
of these things are scary you got ton of
them they could do some serious damage
and that was really well done and it
gave us some new aspects of them to keep
it fresh angel in Manhattan
push the believability of them a little
bit but the notion of what they were
doing was scary enough and the emotional
impact of what happened late in that
episode was powerful enough that it
still worked they did just get tossed
into a couple things later on with
things like time of the doctor but they
were just sort of there cuz well it's
it's Matt Smith's last episode we gotta
have them well no you shouldn't have I
thought that that kind of cheapen them a
little bit but they're still amazingly
effective villains number two the
silence now I know that people who
prefer the weeping angels are gonna
point out that it that this gimmick for
the silence is almost identical to the
weeping angels the reasons are different
but in both cases you can't look away
from them or you're dead now I
appreciate that but the mechanics of the
silence of the reason you can't look
away from them unnerved me a lot more
than the weeping angels because the
weeping angels if you know what they are
you know that if you're looking at them
you are still safe the silence first of
all looking at them does not make you
any safer cuz they can still kill you no
matter what but the instant you turn
away that you just even forget you're in
danger and just messing with your head
like that that sort of pushes my buttons
in terms of what unnerves me a little
bit more than living statues now the
weeping angels work very well in terms
of that hiding in plain sight but the
idea that a silence could literally walk
down the street and nobody would
remember seeing it that just really
creeps me out and I love the design it
is evocative of sort of that classic
sort of general alien design and but
then paired with the suit and just the
lack of a mouth and the physicality of
the performers that they use all just
adds up to an insanely effective villain
that I think has been used extremely
well pretty much every single time
they've turned up what's at number one
was there ever any doubt
really the Daleks now have the Daleks
had a perfect string of hits with every
single appearance well no but the only
big misfire that they had was Daleks in
manehattan evolution of the Daleks
two-parter and the thing is though the
ideas behind that one are really solid
the execution is a complete mess but
that is not the fault of these
characters
as villains I think they are amazing now
just as much as they were in the classic
era they were introduced perfectly with
Dalek and then you just sold you the
idea of one of these things it's
terrifying and then you had to deal with
armies of them you had to deal with the
emperor dial fader the supreme Dalek I'm
actually really big sucker for the new
paradigm Daleks I do feel like we didn't
get the mileage out of those we should
have because it feels like the show kind
of pulled back from that idea when most
fans didn't react so well to it I really
like them and I kind of wish we had done
more of that if nothing else I want to
know what the heck and eternal is
because you remember that they all set
all the different colors somewhat their
jobs was and it was things like supreme
scientist soldier one of them said
eternal what is an eternal Dalek I wanna
know or another appearance I love asylum
of the Daleks seeing Daleks
fully-functional that's scary but seeing
crazed Daleks that not even they can
control it's a little bit like what I
said before with the master being
unhinged something that can tear you
apart when it's collected that's scary
that same thing now completely bonkers
that's terrifying I do think that they
sort of reversed the Daleks forgetting
who the doctor was a little sooner I
think they should have strung that out
at least for another full season before
they found out who he was again but
again that's not a fault for these
villains and they are used really really
well whether it is a single Dalek
appearing briefly or whether it is a
horde of them coming at you somehow they
really manage to keep them up even
though you know they get defeated
repeatedly they should be a joke by now
just look at the design it's a rolling
trash can with a plunger how can that
work they make it work it's been working
since the early days it still works now
Daleks
number one you knew it was gonna be the
case so that's my ranking for recurring
current age Doctor Who villains what
about you what's your number one is that
the Daleks is it something else drop it
down in the comments let's talk about it
but until next time this council is
adjourned